(upbeat pop music)
- [Voiceover] Big League Chew.
- [Voiceover] We have
Wild Pitch Watermelon
- [both] and Out-of-Here Original.
- Oh it's like shaved cheese.
- Oh my God.
- It's uh--
- String.
- [Woman] String.
- Yea it's actually really good.
- It makes me feel like
I'm having a snack.
- Sort of like a marshmallow.
- Yea.
- When you first bite into it
- Definitely like a marshmallow.
- Yea.
- It's fun.
- It tastes like winning.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Woo, Bazooka, I like the name.
- I feel like this should
already be in my mouth.
- This is the best so far for me.
- It's so hard to chew on.
- It's like a pebble.
- This is more like
concrete than the first one.
- I'd chew on this when
I'm extremely enraged,
you know.
(snarls viciously)
- I don't know, it kind of reminds me
a bit of a Beyonce album
whenever it comes out
you have no idea what's in it,
but you know it's gonna be good.
(playful guitar music)
- [Voiceover] Dubble--
- [Voiceover] Dubble Bubble.
It's like my candy flavored
dreams, this looks amazing.
(playful guitar music)
- Tough.
- Oh, that's so hard.
- There's no bubble.
- No.
- It tastes like bubble gum
that's already been chewed
for about an hour.
- It's like chewing on clay.
- Leonard DiCaprio, 'cause this gum
is never gonna win any awards.
- But the difference is
that Leonardo DiCaprio
deserves to win an award.
(playful pop music)
- [Voiceover] Fruit Stripe.
- I'm getting nothing out of this.
- You get tats though.
- When I stuck it in my mouth,
I felt like I got a paper cut.
It has really sharp corners.
- Sort of reminds me of baking soda.
- Like, it would remind you of childhood,
'cause it's the only
time you'd ever eat it,
and then once you get to a certain age,
you realize that it's
awful and the novelty
of the tattoo wears off, so you move on.
- All the color went into the wrapping.
- If this was a celebrity,
it would probably be Shia Labeouf.
- [Voiceover] Why?
- 'Cause it's horrible.
- [Voiceover] Woo, Starburst.
- The Starbursts in Australia
are really, really popular
but they've never been in gum form before.
I'm excited to try this.
- Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
- Smells like um--
- Heaven.
You know what, I think I
have had one of these before,
in my dream.
- Yea.
- This is nice.
- Definitely something that needs
to be brought to Australia.
- I want a whole like box
of these to take home,
honestly, like this is great stuff.
- I'd say probably reminiscent of Kanye,
can't really like him even if you want to.
- You guys are a lot more
experimental with flavors,
very adventurous.
- I feel like the gum
that America has to offer
promises a lot of things, and
then it just like snatches
them in the night and is like ha, ha,
you thought this was gonna be really good,
but surprise, you're chewing on a rock
and it tastes like Iggy Azalea.
- My jaw is a bit sore
right now, 'cause your gum
is very hard to chew.
- Definitely a thumbs up.
- Yea, I will definitely a thumbs up.
- Thumbs up.
- [Gray Shirt Man] Thumbs up.
- Definitely.
- They're very colorful,
the names a bit wacky,
yea, it's definitely
marketed very differently
to how Australian gum is.
- Yea, yea, Australian
gum's a little bit more
elegant in comparison.
- Mm, the finest of gums.
(laughter erupts)